follow your intuition even though it
doesn't make sense if you love community
you should be responding to them to
comment I think that you should have a
mission and then what you're working
right now I think if you have five your
goals for yourself be thinking small if
you need to practice in the practice of
wanting a piece of equality so let's
talk about the hustle with in the
beginning date with YouTube okay you
don't have a lot million subscribers
into things
yeah how are those early days view in
YouTube so when I first got started on
YouTube I've been trying to famous I
didn't have no need to Commission
something right I think one of the
things that I'm really great at is just
starting stuff with not having
expectations I've so many people build
up this big plan in your hand this new
business you're gonna start becomes this
giant thing and then when you do your
first thing that doesn't take off you
get disappointed like all these people
are growing and Here I am and I suck I
leave my first redevelopments of
comments I started for two reasons one
excellent business and I was getting
asked a lot of questions which was
flattering and so instead of typing
in response I'd rather make video and I
figured you know how to help that person
and maybe they're not telling people to
not millions of people or maybe hundreds
so it made the video and send it to them
as an in an email city to use my
response and then some of the people
watch it that plus I love model success
I love learning from successful people
and I wanted to tell their stories and
Bill Gates take my company knowing that
I met him just his story of life might
be senses that thing that's actually
state my business and so the process of
studying successful people only to learn
from them I found really helpful for me
that's what I wanted to share that with
other people as well so it was a hobby
just like that you know I'm going to do
this see how it goes and as I got more
into it I like the process and so I
checked doing it and I had my channel
for just over ten years then when I got
the name not that I was actually like
the illicit content but I've been
serious about it for the past five or so
years four and a half years ago I had
7000 subscribers 107 thousand
subscribers networks at one point six at
one point seven other times comes in and
it's by doing three videos a day but
that's when I started taking seriously
there's one of them maybe the content
consistent I think the the quantity
beats of quality so the more you do the
better you get
this thing feels better than the first
thing to do and if we look I had like my
dreams come back to here click on and
say you're so bad getting that right
that the more you do the better you get
so if you're only making a video a week
it's hard to get good really really good
skills if you practice anything 52 times
a year if you only saw your wife once a
week like that doesn't it right if you
need the practice the practice is
quantity leads to the quality and then
when you're making widely then you start
paying attention to what's working
what's not working what kind of
questions to it like that house you get
to the hacks at YouTube but I think that
the very early days it's important to
follow your intuition even though it
doesn't make sense you know keep
following your intuition you know you're
not getting the results but you get 19
you just walk and you do it and be
playful upbeat curious and be gentle on
yourself that you may not be getting
there was also complete because if you
keep doing the work you will eventually
get the results right what do you wasn't
to use you know focus on the totally
people coming to individuals or
supporting the small following that
there's a lot of people I think we tend
to you know get this variation and we're
even reply to them to people that
comment on our videos and we're worried
about you know 100 comments how did you
focus on that how did you feel and say
you know what these two people want then
you're grateful I think that's a
personality thing I think it's a
discipline different ways to win and
that's why that's why it's great because
you can win as you you gotta find your
own path to winning so for me I love the
community stuff I think the purpose when
champagne I started so much as an
entrepreneur and was broke and felt like
a total loser
and so I I resonate more still would
like the startup doing a part-time
trying to get my business on brand that
I do with the people who exited me tons
of money I
still I see myself as the startup and so
those are the people are going to help
and so I love the community stuff that's
a way that you can't win like if you
love community you should be responding
to every comment even now in this month
every common hire review somebody on my
bill and he responds to most of them and
and I say he saves them for me the ones
that I need to give attention to and I
think it's important I think it's a
great strategy but if you're only doing
it for strategy you're probably going to
lose like you just responding to
comments saying thanks for comment but
the hearts out there and you're doing
this you feel forced to do it you're
gonna lose
you have your friends never caught
Michael YouTube channel now you became
relevant but he became a speaker yeah
how did that so similar path where I
think that you should have a mission and
then what you working right now
I think if you have five your goals for
yourself be thinking small so I got my
girls myself I think they know what
you're capable of in five years is
ridiculous like you would just look at
you two years ago
you're just person your goals five years
ago a total different than when you're
right now and so you can you can set up
your goal and hit it but I can see you
don't have any small like you could have
been doing way more if you'd listen to
intuition more have more flexibility so
I think you have a purpose
mission that is that right like believe
for me I'm only going to believe people
more believe in entrepreneurs more and
that's travels because problem on top
potentially that's forever how I do it
will change a lot from that until I die
so I never filed an author because I
thought what he's a book like you'll be
able to open doors anymore right it used
to be that was the only way to get in is
the only way to be seen in the next week
to have a book I need a book anymore
I never thought I'd be speaker because
arch bears don't have money so they're
not gonna hire me to speak and so
corporation of money but I'm going to go
to or you can tell that a team could be
entrepreneurs like this who's gonna hire
to be speaker so all the stuff that I'm
making my doctor I think ever thought
was gonna happen
I just kept going here here's the start
of my speaking was even the for me to
channel I had sold it business I got
invited to speak at a whole bunch of
different international events was
plenty to so young success story kind of
thing and then how I don't something's
wrong
[Music]
place it so I set up an event with the
YMCA my little wife and you don't
respect the police prevent and manage
everything just take it back just to
have a local program and three people
who showed up and if my heart like stops
like you know like it did all this work
promoting and they were providing and
had this big grown woman only three
people showed up I'm never gonna like
how am I ever gonna tourism food the
business but three people showed up so I
okay the show was to go on we're like
and I help these three people and it was
awesome you know I helped those three
people and then we went to the Starbucks
and the street contains a conversation
and I remember just feeling I don't know
if I'm ever gonna make money doing this
but I have to keep going because it
feels that fills me up it fills my soul
and then I just packed away and
eventually turned into something and
then I got my first international
speaking gig paid was in Malaysia where
the resentment had limited my man you
know a speech for us in Malaysia sure
and then I got opportunity to create a
book and I got opportunities come to me
which would be the same thing for you as
you keep chasing down your dream as you
keep building an audience of the
momentum opportunity will find you now
if you have an ambition when I want
right
you can make that path little bit easier
I never cared about write the book that
my answer and that stuff I care about my
mission and how accomplished that's
gonna change many times but basically my
business model is I kick up a lot of
noise in my industry and then people
come with me with opportunities so in
the world of entrepreneurship if you're
not too preneur probably seeing my
content whether you know my name or not
probably when my videos if you're not an
acquaintance so you get really
well-known within and you should within
an industry and then if you are one of
the back set what you do more
opportunities on my plate than I am if
you want to know some more YouTube
growth hacks from some of the best in
the industry check the video next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
a lot of creators when they start off
trying to grow YouTube channel they
usually think in terms of creating
really amazing high production video
quality content